non mais c'est vrai que Thomas quand tu
dis euh quand je vois Rachida Dati en
robe Dior sur la couverture de match je
vois la Rachida de mon quartier Camille
je tenais un mec de Neuilly non non non
je suis d'accord
alors vous êtes aussi chroniqueur chez
Laurent Ruquier sur Europe 1 c'est
particulier si tu veux comme atmosphère
c'est à dire que c'est une émission qui
s'appelle on va se gêner qui diffusé de
16h à 18h tous les jours mais tu
enregistres à 8h du matin oh là là donc
tu te lèves et c'est blague blague
les yeux très rouge très très fatigué
heureusement que c'est de la radio
c'est vrai que les gens sont beaucoup
plus laids qu'à la télé en général
et c'est vrai que Laurent vous a
présenté comme Fabrice Éboué de
sauvetage ouais
et ben tu vois c'est tout à fait le
style de jeu de mots qu'on aime chez
Europe 1 voilà mais toi tu n'écris pas
tes blagues il me semble non non c'est
pour ça une blague aussi
est-ce que Christine Bravo vous a bizuté
non je crois tout simplement qu'elle a
arrêté l'alcool elle est assez saine
depuis donc on a pas eu le temps de
s'habituer tous les deux mais c'est une
très bonne camarade en tout cas moi
aussi vous étiez là quand Jean-Marie
Bigard a fait part de ses doutes sur le
11 septembre j'étais à deux places de
lui et vous avez rien dit au début c'est
du Jean-Marie Bigard classieux comme on
l'aime si tu veux et commence par une
blague je crois il nous raconter que
penser vacance il est méfier dans la mer
ou un truc c'est du Bigard non mais du
Bigard comme on aime moi j'aime ça il
fait bon et tout d'un coup je sais pas
pourquoi le mec vrille tout d'un coup si
tu veux et commence à nous parler et le
11 septembre le passeport il était
intacte le Pentagone c'est des conneries
ça n'a pas existé tu sais moi je Jumet
un coup de coude comme ça je lui dis
Jean-Marie déjà tu as un prénom un peu
douteux
tu sais ils ont sorti le grand mot du
chapeau ils ont dit révisionnisme je
pense pas que Jean-Marie Bigard soit en
tout cas bon voilà il s'est excusé c'est
super close mais c'est vrai il a soutenu
que le 11 septembre en fait avait eu
lieu le 12 vous êtes au courant de ça
aussi ça vous pensez qu'il y a des
choses qu'on nous cache tout qu'on nous
dit rien sur cette affaire du 11
septembre moi je pense qu'il y a quand
même je pense qu'il faut rire et
heureusement qu'il y a des gens comme
vous ça fait du bien mais il y a des
moments font quand même donc vous
trouvez Jean-Marie moins drôle quand il
fait ça quoi je dois dire que en ce qui
le concerne même quand il fait autre
chose
même quand
[Musique]
Thomas Jamel Comedy Club aussi avec
votre spectacle le titre est déjà un peu
mieux vous c'est Thomas and Jijel est un
bloc un bloc ça veut dire
un petit jeu de mots en plus avec mes
origines sociales un peu bloc bloc de
béton bloc de cité tout ça il y a un
petit assez fort Thierry attention
c'est du mardi au samedi à 21h45
alors vous êtes aussi chroniqueur vous
alors vous c'est pas Laurent Ruquier
c'est Stéphane Bern hein au Fou du Roi
il vous a bizuté Stéphane Bern non non
non
tranquille donc vous avez en commun de
pas trop apprécier Rachida Dati Rama
Yade Fadela
oh non c'est c'est un raccourci un peu
rapide c'est pour ne pas dire qu'on les
apprécie pas lui les appelle le BEP
coiffure quand même non
c'est
écoute
c'est sorti de son contexte on voudrait
absolument pas passer pour des gens
surtout avec nos gueules quand on a
enfin trois personnes d'origine
maghrébine ou africaine au gouvernement
pour des gens qui systématiquement vont
les taper alors que c'est un progrès
c'est une solution
quand je vois Rachida Dati en robe Dior
sur la couverture de match je vois la
Rachida de mon quartier Camille je
tenais un mec de Neuilly non non non non
je suis d'accord
non non mais le truc qu'il y a c'est que
on a tellement peu de représentants que
je me dis que la sobriété et quand même
importante pour nous tu vois je je par
exemple si je venais là avec Fabrice
avec des chaînes en noir et tout tu vois
les ça va il faut que caricaturer vu
qu'on n'est pas beaucoup et que je vois
l'une des rares représentantes venant du
même milieu social que moi avec des
robes Dior tout ça c'est un peu gênant
vous dites quoi dans votre spectacle le
sujet de vos anciens employeurs sur
Fogiel tu dis quoi dans ton spectacle
une chose qui est extraordinaire c'est
que moi je suis rentré un peu dans dans
ce métier dans ce game en triangle
Djamel Debbouze et Jamel a un effet
extraordinaire si tu travailles avec
Jamel Debbouze il y a des milliers de
gens qui t'aiment et tout de suite alors
que Marc Ollier Fogiel allait faire tu
travailles avec Fogiel
moi je vais passer dans la rue comme ça
les gens qui me faisaient fils de [ __ ]
tu disais pourquoi quand chez
Marc-Olivier Fogiel tu es chargé de
faire le méchant parce que c'était mon
rôle
j'étais sur en plus sur un perchoir
comme un vautour comme ça
direct donc c'est s'enfiler quand je me
plante je me plante et je dis mais
ce qui est extraordinaire j'ai eu cette
émission par exemple où je me suis
embrouillé avec Faudel le chanteur parce
qu'on recevait dans cette émission le
greffé des mains en tant entendu parler
vous savez ce monsieur qui a une idée
extraordinaire il a fait partir une
fusée de feu d'artifice mais comme ça
donc il s'est passé le drame qui devait
se passer il perd ses deux mains il
récupère de nouvelles mains et il dit il
y a pas de souci on peut déconner sur le
sujet donc moi je me lâche comme
d'habitude j'ai pas le choix c'est le
métier du vautour si vous voulez et là
il se trouve que le mec avait des bagues
sur quasiment tous les doigts et je lui
dis les bagues elle s'était déjà là
vous les avez ratés sur les bords
et j'ai Fodel qui me regarde dans le
fond et je peux me faire mettre à la
menthe par n'importe qui il y a pas de
souci mais pas Faudel quoi c'est juste
[Applaudissements]
en fait je te raconte en fait la fois
l'émission qui m'a le plus marqué moi
pour des bonnes et mauvaises raisons
c'est la fois où Nicolas Sarkozy était
venu en fait et quand il est arrivé
c'était vraiment le premier club de
France quoi il est arrivé déjà il m'a
serré la main tu vois il a essayé de
m'impressionner quoi il était vraiment
là baisse les yeux quoi et moi j'ai
vraiment monté j'étais là bah tu
regardais comme ça
à un moment donné
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu